hello and welcome to this video this is
just a short one roughly
minutes I don't have more time but I
also want to again get some feedback on
the audio setup this is um again a
little bit of a change set up the audio
was better last time but I decided to
try something else again using my old
microphone and I gave a test recording
to people who liked it a lot um we'll
see what happens in the meantime I got a
reversed Benoni here against bravado
chess this is not a usual opening for me
I'm not a real fan of the Benoni but if
you play what I played a ready style
opening you sometimes get them and there
are versions of this benoni that are not
so bad I think this is one of them we'll
see what happens
I was happy to play ninety five to trade
off
one minor piece in general in the benoni
this is an interesting moment because I
could go to b5 the kind of thing that
could backfire badly in the brownie you
want to trade pieces and minor pieces
that is and the trade on e5 was one of
those traits that is an interesting move
he tries to maybe trap my roof even you
know Bishop d7 coming up
yeah that's definitely a thing yeah
maybe this rook maneuver was not the
best of ideas but will seem night if
form mmm this has to go Queen seven and
I could trade but then the rook would
have a really strange way all the way
over
yeah don't really see much else Queen
takes and now what will be three this
Bishop a form gathered only leaves this
odd square this might not be so bad
actually I'm not entirely sure the rook
is a little bit strangely placed which
it's not clear that it is so terrible
probably him
before might even be some kind of threat
okay you know this is an interesting
interesting move
I don't want to take that's not really
so great look he has such a strange
piece at school him be takes rook takes
at least he was hanging twice using
using both rooks in this case we'll see
if he actually wants to take but he has
to do something I'm yeah this is also
one of those moves that does something
preventing c5
yeah I'm not so happy here but this
could be interesting both attacking a5
and threatening Queen h6
maybe interesting I still have one
minute 10 yeah taking taking a five
people take on a C form not sure about
this but maybe this one one idea that
also you need to have on the radar is
rook takes h5 in some cases which could
be a draw okay yeah probably
this one it's probably quite draws
position we're just kind of reasonable
given that I was never better
maybe he can actually do something here
based on the pin mm something like that
somebody somewhat of an annoyance so I
probably have to do this prepare King f2
Massey porn is not an S that you can
always play rook c1 and simply stop any
possible activity okay here maybe
and try to show what the bishop is up to
going to be three or yeah
I expect him to go to f6 I'm going back
cannot be a solution okay I'm interested
so he's basically just accepting to be
somewhat somewhat worse it is of course
nothing serious but still I didn't
expect it to go like that
[Music]
it's just nothing going on I have the
slightly better pawn structure but you
just don't win a position like that I
cannot at all get the King to activity
and now the rookie at least has a good
square looking at age five and attacking
g3 at the same time it could be helpful
now the goal is seven and he's going to
that doesn't help at all
yeah the F point is somewhat is fast but
hey it's very fast but is it winning
yeah I think I think it is just about
rookie aid coming
I wanted to go to g5 it doesn't matter
rate him
yeah it was a bit odd
I shouldn't not not really win this but
okay so maybe just a quick look again
I'm a little bit under time constraints
so here
the computer is has the supposition as
somewhat in protocol and I would be
surprised if it wasn't like that for
quite a while okay here he five is very
strong for black that makes a lot of
sense cover de for win before and this
is probably not so great in comparison
but still of course some a draw is very
very likely I was surprised that he
actually went into this because it's it
might be a draw but the game still
continues for quite a while and this is
also a draw probably only later in
sports and I'm just clicking through
this quite quickly
v king is seven okay three this is
losing yes to go rook f3 okay because
now I'm not actually making progress
this is a very tough move to play it
looks so awful to step into the check
but it doesn't help because here now
upon is stopped and only here he is
indeed losing no chance whatsoever okay
so next game let's see what we get three
plus two against one player two
- doc is taking a good amount of time in
this very early position
should be six a bit odd because now you
have to enter this ending which is
pretty terrible yeah you can argue about
the phrasing terrible it's just not good
for black because you lose a ton of time
and you have absolutely no compensation
for that the bishop is just not in a
good spot on c7 and yam should be rather
problematic for black this whole thing
so when it state look a six already is a
thing question is if I should do it now
on wait that's always a tough one
yeah I think I can do it now
I mean I can definitely do it now but I
mean is it the right timing to play the
move so I'm winning this tempo
basically and now have to improve on
this one okay six okay so I'm not easy
to claim I just want to double against
the a pawn it's my idea and now that
that's wet what are you doing on edge
592
kingi - okay one night h5 is just not a
good move I mean III as part of my setup
anyway so he's just Miss placing the
piece or all the ideas totally beyond me
I don't I don't know yes he can take b3
but I can take a seven and that is a
very good type of trade yeah all this
one that doesn't matter who is six
and um rupee one yeah utilizing this pin
it's always scary they play move that
you did not at all consider
hmm Wow it's not so easy I mean I should
be quite a bit better but still it's not
super obvious how do you get down not to
be six maybe
not sure what he's trying to tell me
so he has a check here but I can also
just takes his six then Bishop f4 was
what he wants to do so I'm simply
stepping out of the check and now black
resigns I guess yeah okay this is a move
but you are simply not going to hold
this position so do I just take on rook
a seven is also very strong yeah this is
stronger now how do we play it's
probably a good idea to to keep efore
and g4 covered and then enter with the
bishop I'm not sure maybe I should have
just traded rooks it could have been
maybe it was even easier not probably
objectively strongest way to play but
maybe the easiest way to play this is
this is still not totally totally simple
and I don't want to do that no I did not
play this well
well what was the message all about it's
no idea what he wrote during the play am
i doing a bit well mr. teacher I'm not
sure if this is just yeah touch the same
yeah so I think the position here looks
pretty good for white but the conversion
is this is very bad all night eh 5 is
clearly a bad move because you're
forcing and move with black that white
will play no matter what um this is just
not at all good
I definitely did not play in the best
possible way okay seven already was a
bit better but I doubt that I ever let
it totally slip okay one 96-97
Bishop f1 here was a complete win okay
simply preparing to put something on b5
that's very very convincing here I
should just trade works keep it simple
but I think the position is always
winning it's just too much C pawn is too
much of an advantage yeah I just have a
new queen okay so let's see one more
game maybe maybe two let's see how quick
this one is and then we can reconsider
that takes a bit of time even though
it's on Saturday evening DHS has 82,000
players on 82,000 that's an awful lot
still even think about you know it's
Saturday evening and large parts of the
world stay at home and only 80,000 why
not
800,000 ok let's play guess who's back
I have no clue yeah mainline rasoolum Oh
a4 should almost always be answered with
a 5 not going to reinvent the wheel just
do it
hmm so [ __ ] was hanging him and he does
not care you know doesn't really matter
that much okay so if I take now look be
one Bishop g7 night c4m claiming that
this is too much too quick you can
probably claim that okay a move that you
always have to check here is the move B
form which completely busts open the
Queen side often you should play with
the aid to be prepared for that this is
very slow
it's very slow
let's see yeah okay
I mean I called it yeah but you still
okay I can take on c4 first night Jiggs
sometimes you can play b5 not here
though
yeah I mean I said that this is going to
happen but you saw hope which it is not
that terrible but it is pretty terrible
as Cicero is annoying and you actually
know what's going to happen and you're
still not preventing it you can also not
give the exchange unfortunately
yeah I kind of relied on finding
something it but yeah it was just as bad
as I expected or feared it would be
instead of matter of six I can simply
play a prophylactic move and probably
should be okay
a little bit surprised that he actually
takes time there it's not over yeah I
mean the position is very bad for black
but it's not yet a complete loss at
least not in a typical human player game
I managed to castle this is a huge
accomplishment
maybe just look everyone look a to
everyone and I just got back then I
guess idea Queen c7 the a pawn is not
really a huge asset for him I'm not sure
that f4 was an ideal solution look a f1
may I go rook f8 and I only got 10
seconds though that will almost
certainly be a huge factor
Queen a7 check out song let's do this
grab this pawn and it's all of a sudden
equal material who would have thought
lukkage with my idea
now that looks okay really he has to go
look deform okay what is the idea I
don't get this move at all this is
encouraged so I have all the time to try
to figure out a way forward probably
isn't one but I can still try
so any point in doing this probably not
but I have to do it yeah okay it's a
draw but given how the game went I'm
definitely going to try okay what is the
possible somewhat possible way to do
stuff really it's no good way
hmm I know I'm just moving around I just
while moving around tried to figure out
if there is some way to do stuff okay
just going a five this have caused
extremely dry switch anyway it's it's
what it is the Jeep on you can even go
for passive defense
it's some really making any sense
what's the clock saying Kim you cannot
do anything I mean absolutely nothing
yeah hmm you should probably win the
game of course in the opening if we
recheck this briefly again I mean I was
perfectly aware of the motif but I
didn't stop it
yeah indeed once the gunite is seven but
just maybe a better choice after that
okay so b5 is in fact possible I was not
aware of that a takes he takes C takes
Knight a5 and then dysphonia this is
okay for sure okay so I can indeed play
this but I have to react correctly I
took and did this and after a5 I'm in
bad shape it doesn't seem to be lost
straightaway which is very close with
the check oh my god did not see that at
all oh my god and at the end and again
c5 wins or want to know did he ever win
no I was just an engine we had engine
behavior very strange yeah so at the end
it was a draw in the ending you cannot
do all that much please let me know
about the sound quality would be good to
know if this is a sustainable setup or
not thanks a lot for watching